哈囉大家今天呢我們要講TrackGP的深層圖片
最近這個吉普利風格的照片太夯了吧
只是每個人都在TrackGP上面做自己吉普利的照片
但是其實呢他可以做的不只是這個風格相關的照片
還可以做其他很多的事情
例如說我們今天呢就會介紹到
如何製作你自己的Line貼圖
自己的Logo或者是室內設計
甚至是商品渲染全部都可以
而且我們會直接告訴大家提示詞到底該怎麼寫
然後呢在上一部影片有很多人提到的一些問題
我覺得非常的好
例如说问说可不可以商用啊
或者是免费版跟付费版到底有没有差异
我们今天呢也直接实测给大家看喔
那在开始之前呢
我们先解答一下询问度最高
就是第一名的这个问题
就是到底有没有免费版可以使用
答案是有的
但是之前呢可能是只有部分开放
但是在现在这一刻开始呢
他们已经像全部的这个免费用户
都已经开放可以生成图片了
那免费版大约是一天两三张的额度
可能之后会越来越多啦
然后还有呢就是今天讲到这些提示词
其实不用照操
因为里面很多提示词都是
我问AI然后他帮我想的一些提示词
例如说你想要生成一些不同风格的这个图片
但是你一时想不起来
到底有哪些风格的话
你就可以直接询问AI
你就说有没有类似吉普利的风格
然后一些动漫的风格什么的
可以让你参考
那你就可以请他列个10个20个出来
那你再去选就好了
所以你就是不太需要自己去想
所以接下来呢我们直接来看看
就是10个超萌的ChairGPT生涂用法
那首先第一个我们要来看一下
如何制作专属于你的LINE贴图
那今天的做法就是你直接把你的照片
或是你想要的参考的图片
例如说宠物啊
或者是一些动物的图片直接丢进来
例如说我就丢了自己的照片
然后下面呢这个提示词
蛮简单的
就是因为现在它可以生成透明背景的这种图片嘛
所以我就说我要透明背景的九个贴纸
然后呢它有不同的表情跟动作
快乐开心生气等等的
就是你可以全部列出来
也可以不用全部列出来
然后正方形
平面日系可爱风这句非常的重要
就是有些人会觉得他风格画出来
效果不是很好
可能就是这个风格需要稍微调整一下
那我自己使用的用词就是
这个日系可爱风
然后实用的表情贴图
接下来呢你还可以加入自己想要的中文字
例如说你想要加超赞
或是不可能
或是才不要
这种字呢你也可以指定他写出来
然后你也可以每一个都写
例如说你就列个九个表情符号
然后这九个表情符号分别要加哪些字
你都可以详细的列出来
但效果就是中文字太多的话
有时候效果不是很好
不过就是可以尝试看看啦
目前我加了
就是两三个都是没有问题的
然后最后强调了一下服装要一样
然后最后的出来的成果
相当的不错吧
表情都还蛮到位的
然后上面呢都有加中文字
相当的实用啊
这个根本就可以直接上架LINE官方
那如果你想要上架LINE官方的话
你就是要把它剪下来
可能就是正方形
然后给它裁个9个
就可以直接丢给LINE官方了这样子
非常的快速
然后呢也要稍微注意一下
就是你新开一个聊天室
有的时候用一样的这个提示词进去出来的风格
还是会稍微一点点不一样
所以如果你想要做相同一模一样的风格的话
最好就是在同一个聊天室下面继续生成
它的风格才会比较接近喔
好然后再来下一个呢
我觉得也超猛的就是你可以自己做logo
就是例如说抽象
现在很流行那种比较极简风格的logo
它都可以直接帮你做出来
而且你甚至可以指定颜色你知道吗
怎么指定颜色呢
例如说我们现在看这个这个例子
我就是直接把这种色码直接打上去
那这种色码呢他就可以立刻看懂
这几个颜色呢他实际上是这个样子
那我们看一下这个提示词喔
我说呢我要极简抽象风
然后三角形的组合山脉剪影
然后只有用这几个颜色
然后形状简化至极致
我觉得这个还蛮重要的
因为有时候你跟他说极简风
他反而会做出那种
像Canva里面用的那种小图片
反而没有那种logo的感觉
那像这个呢他就是有结合了极简
然后又有一些抽象的概念在里面
我觉得效果很好欸
那上面的这一串呢
其实我是叫AI帮我写的
就是我今天为了要示范logo这个部分呢
我就想说直接让他帮我想一些例子
那他这一段就是直接他帮我写出来的
然后我就丢进来生成图片这样子
你也可以参考我的做法
然后呢你今天做出来这样子
其实你还可以改颜色
然后改材质什么的
我觉得真的超级方便的
例如说我想要改成蓝色
或者是我想要改成橘色
他都自己帮我配好颜色
而且形状基本上是一模一样的
然后呢 例如说我今天想要模拟
它出现在不同材质上面的样子的话呢
它也可以帮我就是模仿出来
有点像是渲染的一个效果
例如说这个是木纹
是不是相当不错
就是很有模有样对不对
这真的很像是一个大牌子的那种
然后最后呢
也可以生成一个比较基础版本的灰阶版
这个就会是比较通用性的一个logo这样子
然后再来下一个来看一下这个是
科技公司的一个logo
那我里面用的字呢是
极简抽象风格
然后几何重叠几何形状设计
然后蓝色帮我指定了这个色码
然后还有纯白色相间
但是我后来有跟他说我想要没有背景
所以他就是没有另外一个颜色这样子
然后简约现代minimal tech风格
然后出来呢我觉得这个也是
感觉就是很像什么大公司的logo
效果很不错
这真的就是可以直接用了吧
对啊
那我们来看一下就是如果要换颜色的话
这个换颜色是有点失败啦
但是因为它今天也只有一个颜色
其实你就可以丢进 Photoshop
这个部分就没有什么问题
再下一个我们要来看商品渲染
那商品渲染呢
其实有很多个不同的渲染的方式
那第一个想要来跟大家讲的是
平面转成3D的状态
就是我们上次有讲到这只猫嘛
这只猫呢例如说我今天想要让它
就是变成现实世界中的商品
或者是一个木偶玩偶之类的话呢
我就是可以直接
请它帮我做成超真实的小公仔
然后它就会出现
但是我觉得让我比较惊艳的部分
就是他还可以换材质跟换颜色
那上面这个小公仔
其实跟他本人长得有
还是有一点落差
但是不知道为什么换成木头之后
就长得超像的
就跟原本的那个平面设计
基本上是一模一样
那接下来我们还可以做更多的变化型
就是我把这张图片下载下来之后呢
我可以请他帮我换背景
直接说把背景换成一个酒吧就好了其实是没有什么技巧在里面啊就是门槛是真的还蛮低的你想要怎么怎么换啊怎么怎么改变这张图片就是基本上很直白的跟他講就好了其实是没有什么技巧在里面啊就是门槛是真的还蛮低的你想要怎么怎么换啊怎么怎么改变这张图片就是基本上很直白的跟他讲就好了
当然有的时候效果出来没有那么好的话
你可能要换一个说法
但是我觉得这一版真的
他的理解力是真的还蛮好的
然后像是这个埃及烤漆啊
就是我换成了一个
比较埃及风的一个背景
然后这只猫也换成了一个
就是比较尊贵的这种材质
那我用的这个提示词就是
帮我换成埃及奢华烤漆材质
然后背景是金字塔壁画
姿势跟表情特色都要一样
就是这么短的一个提示词
就可以把它从这个木头的样子呢
变成一个高级香精的一个猫猫装饰品
然后我们继续看一下其他的这个例子
例如说这个是紫色的女生房间
我就说呢
把这个图片的背景改成一个紫色系的女生房间
其实就是非常的直白
你不觉得吗
然后效果出来就就是很像一个商品罩这样子
然后这个是日系小青星风
然后呢这个是我换材质然后又换背景
那我的提示词是
帮我换成极致奢华的蓝宝石材质
然后背景换成异国宫殿跟蓝宝石很搭
出来就会是这种
平常基本上不太可能会
拍出来的照片的感觉
所以你基本上可以把自己的商品啊
或者是你想要宣传什么东西
你就是把它可能2D短3D之类的
然后再进行这个背景的调换就OK啰
再来下一个我们要来介绍的用法
就是你可以用TrackGPT来生成海报
今天不管是任何的活动
任何的配色 任何的风格
它都可以直接帮你画出来
而且效果超级好
它甚至可以直接帮你写日期在上面
我们上次讲了这个二手市集的海报
我觉得这张的效果很不错
我们来看一下它的提示词
它的提示词是
帮我生成台湾文经二手市集的
宣传平面海报
就这样子一句喔
它就帮我生成了这个
那里面呢你东西其实可以在细条
例如说你可以指定日期
指定时间
指定地址
那这些呢你也可以叫它
就是强制用繁体中文来写都是ok的
那我们来看一下其他的海报
就是说这个台湾手作市集
我的这个提示词是
手作市集平面海报使用温暖的暮色直调
呈现各种手工艺
清楚标示市集的日期地点跟参展位置跟数量
再来呢是一个海洋音乐季的一种海报风格
这个配色我觉得很不错
那我用的提示词是什么呢
就是一个质感台湾音乐季活动海报
融合传统跟现代元素
使用山丸跟音符的设计
然后标明资讯还有表演时间
就是一种复古跟现代融合的这种风格
然后像是夜市文化季
我的提示词是小文青平面海报
使用灯笼跟蓝色招牌
呈现热闹的氛围
这些东西你就是可以自己指定一下
你喜欢怎样的风格这样子
再来下一个要讲到室内设计
还有家具模拟
这是什么意思呢
就是例如说你今天
在网络上面看到一个非常精美的家具图
你想要想象一下
它出现在你房间里面的样子到底是怎样
那你就也可以使用这个Track GPT 的新功能
首先你就是要先拍一下你房间的照片
那我就是给了他这张我们客厅的照片
然后又把它丢入了这个商品照
就是我喜欢这张蓝色的椅子
那想要模拟一下它出现在我们客厅的样子的话
我就是直接跟他说
在第一张照片的空旷区域
加入第二张照片的蓝色椅子
摆得好看一点
如果你不指定摆在哪边的话
他就会乱摆
然后他就给了我这张照片
那张照片很明显就是那个光有落差
所以就会显得这张椅子很突兀
就是好像根本就是随便披上去的这样子
所以我就跟他说光影调整一下
那这边其实你也可以指定
就是室内白日光啊
或者是什么室内怎样的光源
你也可以跟他指定一下
那我就是这样子讲完之后
他就帮我调整了一下这个光影
他看起来效果就自然非常多
而且还蛮不错的
就是好像它真的摆在那边一样
我觉得这个东西就很适合用在室内设计
或者你今天就只是纯粹想要
网拍一些家具什么的话呢
其实用这个效果就会相当的不错
但是要特别注意一下就是尺寸的问题
就是因为它融合呢
它不会真的知道那张椅子到底是多大
所以你还是要稍微注意一下尺寸的部分
然后另外一个例子呢
就是我拍了我房间的照片
也就是现在这个场景的照片
就是这一张
然后呢我就说
我想要换一个颜色换一个配色
换一个风格什么的
我就说把我的房间换成灰蓝配色
他就给了我这张图片
哈
这个超有设计感的
而且而且他其实摆的东西都是一模一样的
他只是帮我换了一个配色
整个呈现的氛围就完全的不一样
效果相当之好
就是看了都很想入住的那种感觉
然后我还做了第二个配色
这个是小清新绿色风格
也是很像人想要拎包入住对不对
我的那个提示词叫做
深层把我的房间换成小清新现代配色
就是这么简单的提示词
它就可以变成这个样子
所以如果你想要改造一下你的房间
想要稍微看一下这个格局
里面有哪些发挥的空间的话
也可以像这样子
直接要它换配色
直接换风格
效果都会很不错
再来下一个呢
这个生成图片应用方法就是画漫画
那这个漫画呢其实生成非常的简单
我的提示词就是帮我生成一个图片
是牛顿解释物理定律的日式漫画
但是语言是英文
也就是说它的语言是可以指定的
然后风格的部分
我就是只有讲日式漫画
我并没有多加解释到底是哪种日式漫画
他就给了我这种风格
所以你其实也可以就是更加详细的描述说
你到底想要画哪一种漫画
是哪一种风格也可以跟他讲
然后主题的部分有没有发现
其实我给他的线索也是非常的少
我只是说牛顿解释物理定律
他就直接帮我把这种分镜啊
这种细节
然后这种对话
然后牛顿的角色
都是他帮我设计出来的
那这个是英文的部分
我们来看一下其他的例子哦
例如说这一张呢
是一个完全不同风格的一张漫画
那这个提示词呢是
帮我申请一个图片是
高坑在大西地创作画作
法国印象派风格漫画
只有带色彩丰富对话使用英文
然后出来就会是这样子的效果
那这些对话什么的
你也可以再更加详细的描述说
例如说你今天是想要做一个比较有梗
可能当下现在有什么热门的话题
你都可以直接要他把这个对话写上去
然后呢
接下来下一个终于出现了繁体中文
繁体中文呢一旦在图片里面多起来的话这个出错的几率就会高蛮多的所以目前可能还没有办法就是升得很完美这样子然后这个提示词呢
就是帮我升上一个图片
然后日式漫画风格的外太空冒险
它遇到了一个外星生物
然后星空背景细节丰富
最后还使用的语言是繁体中文
出来就会是这样子的效果
那它这个呢也是没有分进来
因为它可能没有一个故事线
其实主要就是你要告诉它
有一个故事线的话
它比较可能会出现那种分镜的效果
再来下一个呢也是简单的一个漫画
这个呢却很像是日式复古风格的那种漫画
那我的提示词呢是帮我生成一个图片
是佛洛伊德分析病人梦境的色彩复古漫画风
日式漫画风
然后对话使用简单的繁体中文
就稍微有一点故事的感觉
就是他们有一个对话
然后后面有一些恐怖的东西
也是蛮惊悚的一个感觉
再来下一个用法呢就是生成示意图
这个示意图可以是教科书或是杂志
科学杂志的那种示意图
例如说我们现在画面上面看到
就是台湾原生植物的分布图
刚看上去非常的有模有样
而且真的很像是台湾的植物对不对
然后这张图片我们的提示词
就是一张台湾原生植物分布图
标示不同海拔代表性的植物
加上繁体中文说明文字
适合生态教育展览使用
就这样一个简单的提示词
就可以生成这张图片
其实它的植物都是对的
只是有一些中文字的部分
现在就是没有办法那么完美
不过这些东西其实都很好解决
我觉得最棒的事情就是
其实它已经帮你排版好了
如果你想要真的拿去用的话
你只要把这些部分用Photoshop
就是稍微把字换一下
就可以直接使用啦
它这些植物什么都已经帮你画好了
其实要再修改成可以用的版本
不会很难
就是要修的话其实蛮简单的
然后除了这个植物图之外
还有像是蝴蝶生命周期
这个就很像是我们以前
在教科书上面会看到的那种示范
那它的提示词是画一张
蝴蝶生命周期的教学图表
从软又从涌到成虫的转变过程
每个阶段都加上繁体中文的标注
排版质感是国小自然科学教科书的格式
这个提示词就是还蛮直接的
这个是AI帮我写的
拿出来的效果也是相当的不错
再来第八格要来介绍的这个生成图片用法
就是复古照片上色与修复
以前我们常常看到一些就是
很特别的这种复古照片
你都会幻想说这个实际上
如果是彩色的话到底是什么样子
尤其是这一张呢
这个好像是100年前的这个日本情侣
在家里面的自拍
非常珍贵而且看起来非常恩爱
然后呢我们就可以把它丢进去RGBT
然后我的提示词就是
100年前的情侣黑白照
请帮我上色然后还原真实的情况
他就帮我画出了这一张
虽然说他们两个的脸有一点不一样啦
但是呢还是还是蛮好玩的
就是你可以看到说
实际的情况到底是怎样
然后这是另外一个例子
就是我给他一张黑白照片
然后我就说
请帮我上色完全真实的情况
长相跟动作都要一模一样
那出来呢就是这个样子
非常的真实
肤质很好
真的很栩栩如生
就是他感觉真的活过来那种感觉
那他们两个的长相也没有完全一模一样
就是我发现他是没有办法
完全生成一模一样的脸的
这有可能是为了保护就是大家的个子
因为如果生成一模一样的脸的话
就有可能被拿去乱用嘛
然后给大家看一个
就是今天我大概试完的一个结果
就是我给了他我的脸跟穿搭
然后我想要让他帮我换成网拍的衣服
我想要把它换成紫色这件衣服
结果呢他最后出来给我
给我的是这个
就是脸是完全不一样的嘛
他可能就是在他的资料库里面
找了一个类似我长相的人
然后就把他拼接上去
然后看起来就
不是我们想要的那个效果
所以就是完全不能换脸啦
所以大家就不用想了这样子
好然后再来下一个用法
要来介绍一下
就是用生成图片来制作你的网站
或是App的一些首页草稿
那你可以把它当作是一个灵感来源
或者是直接拿去使用都是没有问题的
就让你看一下
你想要的设计出来的效果是怎样
例如说这个网拍的首页界面
那我的提示词就是
生成一个台湾质感衣服网购首页的设计图片
然后就给我这张
然后依照你不同的产业呢
你就可以把它打进去
例如说主打直缀的台湾本土寡养品牌的官网设计视觉图
然后写繁体中文
然后比例的话你也可以跟它指定
就是今天讲的这些东西
你都是可以指定你要怎样的比例
例如说你想要直的或横的
或者是正方形
你都可以直接跟他讲
那这个出来呢
这个中文还是有一点问题
然后呢因为这个账号是Plus
在前面我们讲的都是用Pro账号生成的
然后现在这个是Plus
因为额度不够了
所以就是用了另外一个账号
然后你就会发现它其实细节还是有差一点
但是我们等一下会更详细的比较这个部分
再下一个我们来讲一下
如何用TrashBee来生成这个生日卡片
而且是专属于你的生日卡片
所以你今天把这个照片丢进去啊
它就可以生成很像你的这种
很温馨的这种生日卡片
而且风格非常的可爱
那我的提示词呢
就是生成一张可爱文心
生日贺卡上面有日系可爱
质感的小人物
那要画出来就是这种风格
还OK啦
那下面这个日文字就是请忽略它
但是上面这部分呢是相当不错的
然后又或者是另外一个例子
就是我给了他这个贾伯斯
还有库克的照片
然后我就说
用这两个人物生成一张
可爱有质感的文青生日贺卡
这出来也不错
就是很美式可爱风的那种感觉
所以大家呢
也可以把自己的宠物啊
或者是你的朋友的照片
家人的照片也丢进去
让他生成看看
出来效果好不好
然后今天呢
我又在做了另外一个
就是比较女生相关主题的
TrueGPD生成图片的应用啊
然后我就又多了几个不同的用法
那其实这个用法呢
这是讲不完
那我现在先讲一个
其中一个我觉得蛮有趣的
就是你可以用它来生成
自己的那个Vision Board
那Vision Board这东西
就是你把你的愿望
然后你想要真的实现的一些愿景
把它制作成一个板子
那你就会去搜集不同的图片什么的
但是如果今天利用这个生成图片的话
你就是可以把自己的照片丢进去
然后生成一些你已经成功的样子
例如说我想要去希腊玩
然后可能我在一个奢华厨房里面做菜
或者是我今天搭了一个头等舱
我就是直接让它生成
那因为我刚才讲过不能生成脸部嘛
所以我们就是用一个背景就是背景的方式呢讓自己過過癮也不是過过瘾啦就是可能把它收集起来然后你每天就是早上可能先过目一遍
你就会提醒一下自己的目标到底是什么
然后你每天都要往这个目标
小小的前景
就是每天至少前景一点的话
离这个目标都会越来越接近的那种感觉
然后我的提示其实很简单啦
就是深层一趟横市照片
然后是我的背影站在私人游影上
欣赏地中海日落
然后象征轻松享受人生
跟财务自由
就是这么的肤浅
就是这么的简单
那你就也可以把自己的照片
跟你想要实践的一些愿景
或者是梦想中的生活结合在一起
这种用法也是还蛮好玩的
好 那我们来看完这个应用方法之后呢
我们来讲几个大家非常关心的问题
首先第一个呢
就是免费版跟付费版的差异啦
那我们现在呢先看一下
我已经帮大家准备好了这个示范
就是我丢进去给他的这个范例呢
是这一张照片
然后呢我用了免费版跟PLUS还有PRO版
各生成了一张图片
就是齐普利风格的这种图片
我给大家五分钟来猜一下
就是哪一张是免费哪一张是PLUS
哪一张是PRO好不好
好大家想好了吗
我来公布答案了
首先呢最左边这一张呢应该很明显
它就是免费版的
就是比较粗糙嘛
然后就是比较随便这样子
例如说后面这个
这个东西不知道是什么
然后呢 再来第二张这个呢
是Pro版
就是最贵一个月要200美金的这个方案
是这个Pro版
然后呢最右边这张呢是Plus版
那这边呢其实蛮有趣的
就是Plus跟Pro这两张
可能有些人会一开始没有办法
分辨出来哪一个到底是Pro
但是其实他们两个里面细节是有差的
虽然说它的风格有一点不一样
就是有些人可能会觉得右边这张
比较符合宫崎骏的风格
它画的是真的还蛮宫崎骏
然后比较吉普利的这种风格
然后中间这一张呢它的风格
有一点不一样
是感觉它好像比较有幼齿还是什么的
但是它里面的细节还是有区别的
就是大家仔细看
例如说我们先看 Plus 的部分
它的扭扣是这种比较手绘
然后比较粗糙
比较像草稿的这种感觉
它是完全没有阴影的这种扭扣
然后我们中间 Pro 版
它扭扣就立刻立体度立刻就出来了
有没有就是有光影的这种表现
然后比较细腻的出力
还有这种衣服的这种车边啊
感觉都是比较精致的感觉
他的衣服感觉是比较贵的
然后看一下plus版的
感觉他的衣服好像就是比较随便的处理
就是一些细节都没有出来这样子
所以有没有差呢是真的有差
而且差不少
那这时候呢有一个很有趣的问题
就是你有沒有办法用免费版
然后叫他画的精细一点
然后达到付费版的效果呢
所以我也实际的来帮大家测试了一下
就是在免费版的部分呢
我一样就是刚刚那一张嘛
然后在下面我就继续问
我就说细节多一点啊
画的清美一点
例如说衣服皱褶扭扣
整张图片很细致很多工
然后呢他的结果就是
就是这个
就是风格整个换了一个
他的确是非常的细致
然后很很多工这种感觉
但是有点too over的感觉
其实有点太夸张了
所以显得很廉价
就是没有那种宫崎骏
然后吉普利的那种风格
所以我下一个
又想要继续叫他用
吉普利风格下去画
但是就达到那个上限了
所以就是一天就只有两张
所以建议大家
如果你现在是用免费版的话呢
你在第一句提问
叫他生成图片的那句话
你一定要讲的更详细一点
就是你一定要叫他细节多一点
然后提示词要更准确一点
就是不要给他随便一句话
让他下去生成
就是感觉是便宜了他啦
那再来呢下一个非常重要的问题
就是我们今天生成的这些图片
到底可不可以商用呢
很多人都在问这个问题哦
那现在商用呢
其实他还算是在一个模糊的地带啦
没有什么法律上面直接讲说
就是AI生成的东西不能用啊
但是就OpenAI自己本身的条款来说呢
他们是说可以商用的
没有错 真的是可以商用哦
但是呢 著作权完全是另外一回事
就是你今天有没有这个东西的著作权
就是还是要看你参与的多广
以下呢 是AI生成告诉我的答案
就是台湾的著作权法呢
主要是保护人类的创作
然后如果你是全部用AI自动生成的内容的话
目前在法律上是不被视为著作的
也就是说你不想有著作权
就是你现在在网络上面生成这些图片
你基本上就是没有著作权这样子
所以既然你没有著作权
那你拿去商用
也就是代表别人也可以拿去商用
除非你有办法证明说
你今天有足够的创作性投入
例如说你有详细的指令啊
大量的编辑修改
然后都是你自己的创意的话
那么你身为人类贡献的部分
就可以受到著作权的保护
那这个界定呢
是不是讲得非常的模糊呢
到底这个比例要占多少
其实我也不知道
所以就是主要还是要去咨询一下律师
才会比较保险啦
还有另外一个非常大的问题就是清权的问题
就是你今天有AI生成图片
如果你去生成了一些别人有著作权
或是别人有商标权的图片太像的话
就会有清权的风险
例如说你可能在自己的图片里面
叫AI画下了宫崎俊笔下的角色
例如说可能是你跟身影少女
你跟魔法公主的合照
或者是图片之类的话
或者是里面有Nike的Logo
这些你拿去商用的话就会清权
但是目前这个TrueHPT里面其实已经先有挡了一层啦
就是它不会让你生成一些
著名的动漫或是卡通电影角色
就是不行是完全不行
或者是你想要生成一些K-pop明星的照片的话也是不行的
还有另外一点呢就是OpenAI他们的服务条款
其实也是不断的在更新
所以现在讲的东西也不一定会是最新的
详细可不可以商用
可不可以有著作权
有没有侵权的问题
有没有一些风险呢
还是要请各位去详洽你们的律师哦
好 那我们今天介绍的
这个ChashV生成图片的用法就介绍到这边
不知道大家最近玩的怎样
有没有什么实际上觉得很厉害的一些心得
或者是有什么样的想法的话
欢迎在下方留言区跟大家一起分享
我自己现在也是在时去摸索的阶段
就是还觉得还蛮好玩的
因为它用法非常的多
然后对实际生活上面也是帮助还蛮大的
所以大家如果想要看更多AI相关的资讯
更多最新的消息或是用法的话
欢迎订阅我们的频道
那我们今天就接下来到这边
我们影片下部再见咯 拜拜